Do you think it's too dangerous?
Because you said even as a Hall
you insisted your grandson
shouldn't play football.
I have a great nephew
who is, you know, football.
He's a it was when he was a fres
He's playing varsity. Right.
I love to watch it,
but I worry about him.
And I was
just reading The Washington Post
as we were talking to Jay there
I was saying, did you give an up
This is DeMar Hanlon's
cardiac arrest
as a wake up call to youth sport
Do you think it's too dangerous?
Well, football is dangerous.
I mean, you have to understand t
even before you step on the fiel
there's a possibility
that you're going to be carried
off the field,
whether it's a knee, ankle,
shoulder back or whatever.
But you don't go in there thinki
that you're going to sustain bra
because with the hits
that you give and receive
that might work its way into
CTE or some kind of of
of
concussion related
symptoms down the road.
What do you mean by that?
When you say that?
Are you saying it shouldn't be p
Are you saying that there need
to be better safety
precautions, better equipment? L
What are you saying?
I'm saying
that the game is a violent game
you know that
you can get hurt physically,
but nobody tells you
that you could get hurt
From a neurological standpoint,
your brain can be changed
in ways that may never make
it if it's you find out
down the road
what damage you may have done.
When I first stepped
on the football field in the nin
I sustained a concussion
and I knew I shouldn't be there
and I quit.
Okay.
The next year I went back
because I didn't like the taste
of quitting in my gut
just to see if I could make it.
And as it turned out,
I wound up being a pretty good p
But I will always remember
those hits that I gave
and and I received on the footba
And I know football is not for e
And I enjoyed playing
but I enjoyed the relationships
that I formed, formed
more than anything else.
You know, I was
I was never really built
to be a football player.
Because I don't have that kind o
violence in me to want to go out
and just smack people around.
If you're I know it's not your d
This is but if you were just say
relative, dad, what would you ad
Would you advise him
if if he had asked me, should my
play, I'd say, well, you know,
whatever you want him to do, tha
that's fine.
And if he asked me,
you know, give me the truth,
should he play?
And I would say, no,
he shouldn't go back.
He should not go back
because you are very sustained a
at some point down the line,
you may sustained another injury
and you might become an altogeth
different person then than you a
So yeah.
Oh, very honestly, I don't
I really don't
want to be the bearer of bad new
but I've been saying this
for a long time.
And
what America saw on Monday night
affects not
necessarily the fathers of young
who want to play.
It's the mothers who saw it.
And they don't want their kids t
go into something like this.
You know, they
you might hurt your ankle,
sprain your ankle or knee or wha
but to get this,
you know,
mothers don't want their kids to
be hurt in any way.
And so that's why
I became like the term of my fam
because I knew
certain things that were not bei
And I told my daughter
my my grandson will not play foo
He was two years old.
And I know it may have been
very difficult for her husband t
And I said, no,
I am the tyrant of this family.
I will be I'm willing to be the
I don't want him playing.
Think we need
I don't want him playing contact